alors au début des années 60 un million
de pieds noirs ont été obligés de
quitter l'algérie
je les ai vus arriver à l'époque et je
peux vous dire que pour eux ça n'a pas
toujours été drôle et à ce moment là un
sur un million a pris un micro une
guitare et il a chanté son pays
ça a marché très très bien après il a
chanté les gens du nord et les français
de france l'ont adopté après il a chanté
la paix et le monde entier l'a adopté 25
ans plus tard il a vendu 10 millions
d'albums
il est toujours dans les dix chanteurs
préférés des français et il vient
d'avoir la légion d'honneur voici enrico
macias
alors qu'il vient de sortir un 45 tours
quel échantillon d'un 33 tours qui
sortira en mars
oui là je viens de sortir deux chansons
de nouvelles chansons et fait partie du
nouvel album que j'ai en train
d'enregistrer en ce moment et qui
sortira vers le mois de mars à peu près
même avant alors soit les chansons le
mieux c'est de les écouter on écoutera
une tout à l'heure ouais avec avec les
petits chanteurs damiette six chanteurs
d'asnières je crois que le mieux le dire
on ne dit pas on le dit on dit pas voilà
mais une question je voulais te poser
c'est que ça commence à marcher très
bien pour toi aux usa on dit même qu'il
va y avoir un gros contrat qui va signer
bientôt on le compare un peu à julio
iglesias non il paraît que ça va oui
c'est un imprésario qui disent ah non
non c'est vrai qu'il ya à cause du non
julio iglesias enrico macias a fini par
a sonné pendant les ascquois vous êtes
tous des rêves
oui non mais il se passe quelque chose
de très important pour moi aux usa c'est
vrai ça fait pas c'est pas nouveau
pas que ça marche mais que je vais aux
usa s'est séparé sans parce que j'y vais
depuis maintenant 15 ans régulièrement
mais maintenant ça commence à prendre
une importance telle que je des fois je
me demande si
si je devais rester là bas mais moi mon
coeur est tout le temps ici en france et
je reviens à chaque fois tu vas me faire
plaisir là oui tu veux pas nous chanter
stranger in the night
bien sûr allons-y et c'était pas prévu à
se dessiner a là rien de prévu un scoop
à la une
c'est tout ce que c'est des problèmes
parce que ça commence à marcher mais tu
es toujours interdit en algérie non oui
oui je suis toujours malheureusement
interdit depuis à part le président
sadate qui m'a ouvert les portes de son
pays
je suis toujours interdit dans pas mal
de pays arabes il se trouve que
l'algérie qui est mon pays le pays où je
suis né je suis encore interdite mais je
dois avouer que il se passe quelque
chose il ya quelque chose dans l'air qui
me fait penser que ça peut s'arranger va
s'arranger mais qu' on est en train de
tout faire pour que j'aille là-bas mais
pas moi c'est à dire que moi je voudrais
que si jamais on m'invite je voudrais
dire que c'est pas un problème d'
orgueil personnel c'est un problème de
symbole pour tous que mes frères pieds
noirs ont subi et que si jamais on m'a
vite ça veut dire qu'on aura fait la
paix avec tous mes frères pieds noirs
très bien et sur le problème des
immigrés en france qu'elle est à quelle
est ta position tu penses qu'ils
devraient voter les travailleurs
immigrés en france
moi je pense qu'un travailleur n'est pas
meilleur qu'un autre sous prétexte qu'il
ait un drapeau différents et que j'ai
vécu exactement la même situation que
les travailleurs immigrés que je suis
contre le problème des frontières
je sais qu'il ya un maximum de français
qui ne pensent pas la même chose que moi
mais moi je ne dis pas les choses en
fonction de ce que pense un maximum de
gens je dis ce que je pense avec mon
coeur moi j'estime que les gens qui
viennent pour travailler qui en plus
sont loin de leur pays et qui en plus
sont loin de leur propre famille est
bien la moindre des choses c'est de bien
les accueillir et
c'est tout je ne vois aucune arrière
pensée c'est à dire que comme ça que je
vois la chose très bien ils vont tous
très très près non c'est gaston oui
alors qui t'appelle encore gaston
aujourd'hui ben tous ceux qui me
connaissent intimement
ah bon ça fait pas mal de gens alors oui
pas mal de gens très bien